if you've ever eaten spaetzle chances
are this is how it was served mixed with
different types of cheese and topped
with glazed onions it's the most popular
way to eat this treat but by no means
the only one spaetzle with lentils is
another favorite long ago it was a meal
eaten by the poor but now a Swabian
noodles are also served as a side dish
with meat saying the name properly
though can be a challenge but spatula
Spacely supposedly we make them on the
board come on bro you have to have the
right flour specular flowers it's a bit
more coarse earth man and my mother
always really enjoyed making them
they're ganna get cooked the ingredients
are simple flour eggs salted water are
mixed in a bowl but preparation is a bit
of a chore the dough has to be beaten
thoroughly to get all the air bubbles
out
there are different ways to cook them up
you can grate them but the dough has to
be very firm
or put the mix through a press that's
the quickest way
the most traditional way is to use a
knife to scrape the soft dough from a
board into boiling water but especially
for thought elevator pressed always
thicker and firmer if they're scraped by
hand the more tender grated ones are
best for cheese spaetzle
they're already creamy aromatic and a
bit cheesy to taste kay is he French
making spaetzle were first mentioned in
print at the beginning of the 18th
century the dish is sent to have
originated in southern Germany in Upper
Swabia this year a museum dedicated to
Spence ler opened in Bart Varzi a spar
town south of Stuttgart it looks back on
at least two centuries of this culinary
specialty the exhibits are made up of
cooking utensils old cookbooks and even
children's toys including this dolls
house from 1870 the museum's director
Heidi Huber has also found rare
cookbooks dating back to 1809 including
one of the first recipes with quantities
what's the target Amelia but when you
make livid spaetzle today and get the
liver from the butcher it's already
prepared and here it says you skinned
scrape and chop 375 grams of calf's
liver types level that's quite a
difference what's inside so you think
that I don't think I'd ever make liver
spaetzle if I had to do all that myself
historian Michelle bar chick has written
a book about 16th century eating habits
spaetzle had not yet appeared something
similar was first created in the 17th
century by chopping dumplings into
little bits starting in the 19th century
the dough was put through Mills grates
and presses to simplify preparation
ideas about the mains origins vary
that's spaetzle if you take the word
spaetzle and leave off the Swabian
diminutive ending la you could have
spaetzle which in Italian means
something like string or lace that's how
it came into Swabian when so he had this
done in slavery chic a common most
families in the region have their very
own special recipe and they're also on
the menu at nearly every restaurant
this not me and it reminds me of my
childhood and simply tastes superb and
for classic spaetzle a regional classic
that's become a favorite food across
Germany